um and next we'll hear from moham ARF
who's from a relational AI we'll also
hear from moham later in the afternoon
during the program plan
sessions thank you I
got I got
volunteered uh twice to give talks here
today so I'm very very happy to um meet
the folks that I'm meeting for the first
time and reconnect with a lot of friends
in the room as well so I think I'm a
little bit of a
novelty uh in this Community because I'm
uh you know helping build a company that
relies very heavily on the uh on the
theory community so okay so uh for the
15 minutes we have today I was going to
just tell you a little bit about the
company and some of the problems that we
are are trying to solve in the afternoon
it'll be more you know more of a history
lesson uh okay so I'm gonna pretend you
are uh a prospective customer if you're
a prospective customer you're typically
like some someone uh called the chief
data officer I don't know if you know
about that role in the company a chief
data officer Chief Information officer
but Chief data officer worries about the
data assets uh for the company and most
companies uh most large companies have
many many many databases that hold lots
and lots of data It's Not Unusual for us
to work with companies that have like
there's one company that talks publicly
about having 17 and a half thousand
sequal databases that have over 400
million Columns of information in them
okay and these this is a company that
works in a regulated industry and if
they build models that crash the economy
they need to be able to provide some you
know uh be able to debug that by going
through and understanding Providence and
data and so on I have another customer
in the Telecommunications industry 180
million Columns of information okay so
Chief data officer worries about the
data assets and today the trend is that
if you have lots of data you're moving
it to a data cloud of some sort uh these
are systems like Snowflake and bigquery
that our database is designed to run on
the cloud and effectively have support
you know infinitely scalable uh data
sets and and and provide infinitely
scalable or effectively I should say uh
infinite Computing ability okay so we're
going to pretend you're one of those so
you're meeting relational Ai and I
introduced us as the AI code processor
for the data Cloud today we're
effectively focused on snowflake as the
first Cloud but eventually we'll work
with others uh so we are the AI
co-processor for the data cloud with
relational knowledge graphs uh so I
typically get some head scratching going
on so I have to Define some of these
terms so what do we mean by ai ai is
super overloaded as you know uh today it
sends for a lot of people it tends to
means it tends to mean language models
uh three four years ago it was deep
learning you know I've been at this
since the early 90s in the early 90s we
called uh called it computational
intelligence or data mining or database
mining it sort of comes and goes in
various hype Cycles okay but as someone
who's also spent the last 30 years or
more building intelligence into uh
Enterprise
decision-making I know that whether
we're building a supply chain
optimization uh uh solution or credit
card fraud detection or Revenue
management solution I know that we need
to combine lots of different modeling
techniques effectively uh and then pick
the right tool for the right part of the
problem okay so the way we Define it is
a uh as a sort of as as a combination of
different techniques needed to improve
decision-making Effectiveness um
analysts like Gartner have called this
composite AI uh they've sometimes called
it neuros symbolic AI uh it doesn't
really matter to me the idea is that
there isn't just one technique to rule
them all and that in practice you need
to do a combination of these things okay
so these things include graph analytics
um you know reasoning with logic and
rules uh mathematical optimization
simulation machine learning as a general
bucket they threw in here and and
language models okay this might you know
this might be suboptimal in some way
let's not quibble over at the idea sort
of there different techniques some
symbolic some subs symbolic or
statistical probabilistic uh that we use
uh to solve hard problems and today I
will focus more on the right hand side
of this equation and maybe next year you
invite me I can tell you more on the on
the left hand side okay so that's what
we mean by AI what do we mean by
co-processor so um this is a you know
kind of a novel thing that we're doing
in terms of sort of go to market in
terms of uh innovation in terms of how
you build a database company and take it
to Market okay if you go and and uh you
know search the internet you'll probably
not not probably you'll definitely find
uh over 800 database systems out there
that have been created by a variety of
academic and Industrial groups just a
ton of databases and people in Industry
really don't want to hear from a
database company coming in and trying to
add one more to the footprint okay
they're chalk full they're trying to go
in the other direction they're trying to
narrow things down to like I just want
to put all the data in Snowflake and be
done okay I don't want to have to manage
uh 800 different database uh systems so
the The Innovation here for us is that
we're going to Market as a co-processor
for systems like Snowflake and bigquery
okay what that means is we it means to
us three things it means one we embed
inside of snowflake okay so we're inside
the security perim perimeter we follow
whatever governance is in place to help
people manage data in Snowflake uh we
also uh eliminate the need to manually
do data synchronization effectively our
system uh shows up as a set of
materialized views inside snowflake that
lets you do things that you wouldn't be
able to do otherwise so this embedded
idea is very important and usually uh at
this point in the conversation the
prospect goes from like you know arms
folded like hurry up because I have I'm
busy I don't have time for you to you
know perking up a little bit because
they really don't want to solve these
types of problems with Point solutions
that force them to copy the data back
out of snowflake and make make it you
know have to replicate security
governance data synchron ation and so on
and then copy it again to feed it to a
rule based system and then copy it again
to do mathematical optimization then
copy it again like that's not the
direction they want to go in okay so
criteria one is being embedded criteria
two is being Cloud native uh a lot of
the point solutions that support these
types of workloads were built on an in
an on premise era they're kind of like
the Hadoop of their workload the Hadoop
of graphs or the Hadoop of rules and so
on and one of the nice things about
Snowflake and the reason people picked
over Hadoop and over terata and natia
and so on is has this really cloud
really Innovative Cloud native
architecture that gives it this
effectively infinite scalability uh you
can do time travel versioning zero copy
cloning uh and you can also offer
snowflake in a consumption based model
where you just pay by the minute or pay
by the hour so you don't have to pre- a
whole bunch of licenses and a whole
bunch of Hardware okay so there's real
business value to those features and
even though when when snowflake was
first created people thought the chances
of survival are very very slim uh the
fact that they had innovated
architecturally and actually built a lot
of what they do on top of immutable data
structure so connection back to Theory
uh uh there uh allowed them to solve a
lot of really practical important
problems okay and then the third uh
criteria is that at the Paradigm level
we're compatible with uh with these data
clouds with systems like snowflake
andary because we're relational they're
relational uh most of sort of the the
operational data for most Enterprises is
stored in tables or uh Json documents
okay and so uh being able to sort of
operate in the same Paradigm means that
you don't have to translate data from a
tabular relational representation to a
navigational representation or pointer
based uh representation or tensor based
representation or thinking about things
imperatively and procedurally and so on
okay so that's uh a sort of uh what we
mean by co-processor okay this point
there's usually a bit of enthusiasm in
the room uh but there's a little bit of
like you know is this for real are you
pulling a fast one okay so so then the
third thing I I I try to explain to
folks is what do we mean by relational
Knowledge Graph um many of you will have
heard the term Knowledge Graph but we've
sort of prefixed it with relational and
I'm going to Define it as uh a
relational holograph is a relational
database organized in graph normal form
uh with relevant domain knowledge
described in an expressive relational
logic uh or relational language okay so
when Ted Cod Theory person first
published on this uh the original uh
relational database work didn't really
uh specify SQL or specify way specific
way of organizing data and you know as
people started to build systems based on
those ideas they started making
compromises because we didn't have all
the algorithms we needed or all the data
structures we needed to make things work
and so TP typically historically data in
in relational databases has been stored
in a denormalized manner because joins
are expensive and I'll create 50 column
tables because then I don't have to
reassemble or rejoin those things
together because joins are expensive and
one of the big knocks on relational
databases was was performance anyways
graph normal form is sort of like the
the ultimate normal form it is atomic
and irreducible and gives us the ability
though to represent present data in a
variety of ways and and tables and
graphs and and so on okay so I'll touch
on that very briefly uh so what do we
how do we represent graphs in a
relational database well you know graphs
can be represented with pointers or with
matrices and so on but obviously a graph
is also representable as a two column
relation connecting you know where every
Edge is a just a row in that in that
relation or in that table so here a
quick example is if I had have a SQL
table like this I can think of the table
as a as a modularity construct that
groups together a a graph that connects
an order to a customer or an order to a
date or an order to a price okay so
tables are just groupings of these sort
of graphs that maybe share a common key
or something okay uh I can also
represent Json documents this way I
won't get into that today Json documents
can be represented actually a couple
different ways uh one is sort of as a
path to a value or two you can think of
Json documents as like being pre-join uh
relational data and we just don't want
to re renormalize it into graph normal
form and of course um I can represent uh
tensors and vectors and matrices this
way as well so a vector is a also a
binary relation with sort of an implicit
index that's the offset into the vector
you know Row one row two Row three and
here are the values Matrix is row column
value tensor you know n dimensional uh
you get the idea and of course you can
express you know operations in in your
algebra uh uh in a fairly
straightforward way and here's even a a
SQL implementation of matrix
multiplication where you're selecting
the rows from a The Columns from B
you're multiplying the values of A and B
and then you're joining uh the a The
Columns from a with the rows from B and
so on okay so these worlds tend to sort
of be separate worlds for people and
we're try of bringing them all into uh
one context okay so I don't have time to
get into it but what the quickly I will
just sort of sketch out when people move
data from 17 and a half thousand SQL
databases into snowflake they're very
happy because now it's One-Stop shop to
go and get all the your bi and your data
scientists or whatever but then they
also realize you have 17 and a half
thousand data models and uh uh schemas
and so on it's still a kind of a bit of
a mess so what the industry is moving
towards is sort of uh building a
semantic layer on top of the 175,000 or
thousands of data silos so that you can
come up with sort of common a common
schema or common ontology for speaking
about uh about that business the other
thing they realize when they move all
that data into uh into snowflake is that
they have you know that data is usually
coming from databases that drive
applications and the application logic
doesn't move so if you're Computing
growth margin or you're Computing
somebody's age from their date of birth
you might have date of birth in a table
but age is typically uh written in Java
and or cobal or something right so
people want to move semantics that are
currently represented procedurally into
this world so that they don't have to
continually uh reimplement and rewrite
semantics lots of good reasons for this
around reusability sharability semantics
are more compact they're more
optimizable they're more portable uh
lots of different approaches to doing
that different languages uh but anyways
I'll close on this so idea here is that
we plug into uh your data cloud of
choice today Snowflake and uh we add
support to for workloads that are not
normally supported that allow you to
express more uh interesting more
intelligent semantics and put them all
in one place sort of in a declarative
Foundation as opposed to having to deal
with the fragmentation and the mix of
modeling techniques and programming
techniques and and all of that stuff all
right so with that I'll uh I'll stop
[Applause]
thanks quick question if someone has
one so here from our next speaker